[Music]
Yaba Sami is an ancient ritual that
practices samurai style archery on
horseback and for 850 years one family
has been keeping this tradition alive
with one of the oldest samurai schools
in the world by day kia motto
okusama is a doctor working to find a
cure for cancer
but by night he's a samurai instructor a
job that has been in his family for
generations
hola Sakamoto mas mas ANCA sorry on
Gonzales okay what accent Musacchio tada
he had amassed a hundred each day many
autonomous Santini de nada de Deus busto
Anwar taka-taka-taka-taka Cara Akuma
demo katakana Shania touchy hello my to
convert a
[Music]
the school teaches the manners and
fundamentals of how samurais moved
students learn how samurais stood how
they use the bow and how they walked but
the most impressive thing the school
teaches is a ritual that was at the
center of what it meant to be a true
samurai drawing a bow and mounting a
horse you mean okay boy
Oh stay pokedex Kodomo dachshund why was
Han Sakura has any ideas and I was a you
take a closer look at your son Anna how
come you know same you know OSR acutally
know kpop you know our Sunni Nicholas
Hank I cannot the privacy
there is a yearly festival for the best
archers to showcase their skills the
course is about 240 metres long and
somewhere classical hunting attire while
shooting at fixed targets on horseback
it's a way to help showcase an important
part of their culture one they hope is
never forgotten o Kesava kini emeritus
hurricane estaba en dakara cooperation
econ zero energy Scotty anywhere Padova
Okajima Sara Ahmadi presenter continents
um can take a hike in Samantha's no
identity to lo tanto de saucé testicle
in Model T sucess Oreo salutes chi gong
coca meaning ahmad they do so no tameni
oh no dental dam you knowit's take a
peek in on day one economic confidence
[Music]